dans
pas les carottes sont cuites bref c'est
lui le cerveau de passe les carottes
sont cuites çà lui doit être fait peu de
passes défendent ils sont huit modes
passent dans les 48 heures pour savoir
la semaine dernière c'étaient les ondes
et qu'est ce que pour cette chaîne se
sent le canton veut c'est ça
et ce à quoi je sers mon fils et moi
j'étais trop bien
messieurs ça fait dix ans qu'on se
connaît on se réunit tous les mois mais
cette fois ci c'est un gros coup ce coup
là c'est le bon rappelez vous il ya dix
ans notre première rencontre je t'avais
convoqué toit doit de fait parce que
dans les mains habiles qui s'est bien
ouvrir les tiroirs caisses
thouars verrais tu sais conduire une
camionnette ouais ouais j'ai toujours
moi le premier quand on fait des courses
avec les copains on m'appelle le
changement doucement pas de culte de la
personnalité et le prof
il ya plus de diplômes à lui seul que
nous tous réunis en effet j'ai failli
réussir le certificat d'études bien
messi avant de commencer je vous propose
d'observer une minute de silence à la
mémoire de riton mort au comptoir il ya
deux jours il est mort et on était avec
lui apporte j'étais complètement moi je
serais pas venu c'est terrible pardon
enlève sa casquette bon la minute à
montfrin signe parce que j'ai pas de
montre
on recommence tom qu'est ce que vous
ferez comme si en 5 secondes de 6,5
secondes de silence top 5 secondes
science c'est bien si vous voulez qu'on
a fait jusqu'à présent c'était de
l'amusé gueule c'était de biscuits
apéritifs maintenant on va penser aux
choses sérieuses vous connaissez tous la
meilleure goriot savait qu'elle est de
mercerie pour les boutiques et bien ce
que je veux c'est la mercerie de la mer
caen
c'est roger dire une chose moi je sais
pas je suis pas content je sais pas sur
les épaules assez solides pour ça il a
raison un trop gros coup je me retire
trop tard bride ans c'est déjà trop
ouais t'as raison c'est un bon coup je
reste
voilà comment ça se présente moi je
serais déjà dans la mercerie à pénétrer
comment je me serais habilement
dissimulé en client est aiguisée comme
en a besoin de se déguiser un gros
bonnet passe inaperçu dans une mercerie
à google quand je voyais pas d'une
question ça on va faire le client mais
qu'est ce que tu vas acheter une paire
de chaussettes une paire de chaussettes
mais mais c'est au moins chez bose
france 65 je me suis renseigné
seulement j'ai avancé l'argent je
l'investis faut se mouiller et c'est là
où la tête du marchand d'armes à papa de
l'année dernière va nous servir
non je vous convoque dans un endroit
isolé alors fait moins de bruit bien
preuves montrent nos le plan
ces implants paris 7 jan
la mère serait il est dans le vaucluse
cerveau je vais poser une question ça ne
te dérange pas que la mercerie soit en
face du commissariat
la clé leur ont fait les coupes à 14h ce
nom là ils sont tous au troc et google
voici les instructions elles sont c'est
les jours oui attention ne pas déchirer
c'est ma soeur qui les a scellé avec la
confiote jolie je découvre en même temps
goût toile toi tu fais tu viendras pied
thoiry
je viendrai avec la camionnette
camouflet en voiture police a essayé à
l'époque c'est bon toi tu dois te faire
pied de prendre les périphériques toi
rire avec sa camionnette lui pendant les
égouts attends attends là ya quelque
chose qui me gêne
il ya deux ans je bute dessus j'arrive
pas savoir ce que c'est reprends toi tu
dois te faire qui était pour les
périphériques touahri est un camionnette
je prends les égouts attend inverse l
inverse ça donne toi doigts de fée à
pied tu prends les égouttoir irin avec
la camionnette tu prends le périphérique
je continue à 14h05 précise le cerveau
pénètre la mer goriot de la mercerie
j'ai voulu faire comme toi j'ai voulu
inverser
bon pour moi douze mois à 14h05 précise
le cerveau achètent des chaussettes qui
doit mettre cinq minutes si je veux dire
tout mon temps commence à bien faire
t'inquiète pas ça fait dix ans que je
drague la mer goriot droite chez dakota
à 14h10 je le rejoins à 14h15 précis toi
toi tu fais tu sors de la plaque d'égout
ouais emplettes cuisine
ouais tu fonces derrière le comptoir des
mers gorbio ya un coffre oui attends je
t'arrête quelques jours des côtes boîtes
de chaussures
quelques voitures 42g combien de temps
une minute temps bien élastique
oui je demande deux minutes accordées
la tension est là ce technocrate pas la
m
à 14h16 précis toi very high tech à
mener oui moi j'arrive dans la personne
soit vide on prend le coffre-fort montée
on se bat la campagne d'un excellent
comment ce qui est nouveau ce week-end
dans ma camionnette marley police bo lg
mini 2 pour ça passe bien et 2 hester or
à la campagne à la mer va les voir des
vacances non mais qu'est ce que tu écris
sur les camionnettes co2 émis deux
prochains dix ans travaille pour rien